welcome everyone
we're delighted to bring you this
session featuring three expert
presentations
focused on how dna is used by law
enforcement and crime labs to solve
prime
at the end of each session there will be
an opportunity for each speaker to take
some of your questions
so please be sure to submit them in the
q a box
as a reminder the session offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
it's my pleasure to introduce you dr
sander knapples from netherlands
forensic institute
who will be cheering this session
um welcome to this uh session
um and thanks to
television scientific for hosting this
uh this event
um of course we would have liked to be
present at a actual meeting
but probably as for most of you
we are all living and working at home at
the moment so what you see in the
background is my home
um but we have found very resourceful
ways to
to come together and
having this online session
um and that also helps us because uh
by doing it online we have the
opportunity to have more people
uh at the meeting itself so today we
have uh three
presentations as louise already said um
and that
covers the the wide variety of doing the
dna
forensic dna profiling um
covering the rapid systems
but also the conventional way of doing
uh sdr genotyping
uh and the the newest technologies like
mps um
so please feel free to um ask your
questions
in the session and hopefully we have
enough time
by the end of this session to to answer
most of them
um so
the first presentation will be given by
martin diepenburg
marta is a postdoc and she's been
working since 2018
in the institute of legal medicine
at the university of munich in germany
before that she worked quite some time
in poland
uh working on the dvi uh project to
identify
uh world's ward victims
uh currently she focuses on the new
techniques
like mps to use for
str and snip typing
and of course many of us use these
techniques already for the most
challenging samples
in the lab and this is also what she is
doing
currently in germany
the title of her presentation is
solving the unsolvable the molecular
identity kit validation of a custom-made
iron
empty stack panel combining ancestry but
also
phenotypical markers so marta
the floor is yours
thanks for the introduction and welcome
everyone
i'm very happy to once again have a
chance to present our work at kids and
i'm very excited that we can have this
meeting as planned uh just in a mutual
form
uh so today during my talk uh i'll try
to answer a question
if we can solve the unsolvable uh with a
snip panel that combines ancestry
and phenotype matters so first i would
like to refer to a paper
that was published in the end of last
year
that summarizes the current state of
phenotyping in europe
and so for those who are interested in
the topic
uh this paper walks you through all of
the available commercial and
non-commercial solutions
for phenotype and ancestry predictions
and what is really important
it also explains the legal situation in
europe
because it varies uh between the
countries uh from those where
phenotyping is forbidden
or not specifically regulated to those
that already
implemented new legislations and now
allow to use phenotyping in practice
so one of them is germany where such a
change happened in the end of 2019
um and now a forensic specialist can be
asked to analyze case work
for phenotype and biological age of an
unknown individual who contributed to
the traits
and we have a special situation in a
federal
state of bavaria where my institute is
located
where such a law exists already since
mid 2018
in an extended forum because it also
allows for ancestry predictions
but the typing can be done only in
special cases
for example to avoid uh serious danger
so in our institute since the end of
2018 we are looking closer
uh how introducing mps would change our
routine work
um and with the platform that we have uh
observing the changing legal situation
and
minding the available commercial
solutions
we decided to go for all-in-one
phenotyping kit
so together with thermal fischer and the
white glove
team we designed uh an iron amp basic
snip panel
and the final version includes 196
targets that cover 202 autosomal hot
spots that are
associated with ancestry and sternotype
and the mean length of the amplifiers is
around 80 base per
and additionally we also added some y
chromosomal markers
in the final number of 120
and they are covered by 130 targets
and their link the main length is around
200 baseball
uh and they covered 20 major haplogroups
from the isoquai phyllo tree and
additionally we have 100 subhaprogroups
for possibly better
phylogenetic resolution so
to sum up those 41 markers we see here
um they built a panel known as high
resplex s
that allows us for eye hair and skin
color predictions
the rest of the autosomal smiths uh are
known as
precision ideology panels for their
ancestry predictions
and as already mentioned we also have
the wise nibs
to understand better than my lineage
and so to test our panel we perform
sensitivity study
for which we selected a normal male
sample and that we diluted from one
nanogram to seven picogram and
amplified it in certificate and the
libraries were done manually
according to guidelines for custom ion
mpc panel
the rest of the workflow was done by ion
chefs and the samples for sequence and
ion s5 with
530 chips and this is the workflow we
use generally for all of the rest of the
samples
so all of the results were reviewed in
converge
but the ancestry and the phenotype
markers were analyzed separately
because the software cannot perform
phenotype predictions
uh so we used this to export the
genotypes
and then we translated them in excel to
get
the input that is required by pyrus
blacks
um as web tool so here are the results
of the phenotype predictions
based on the consensus concerns with
genotypes
consisting of between 40 to 24 snips at
7 picogram
uh showing a decreased accuracy starting
with 62 kilograms
in case of eye and skin color all of the
inputs had the same prediction namely
blue eyes and pale to intermediate skin
and this was
um in accordance with the actual
phenotype of
the individual and for their hair color
uh all except one samples
had light blonde predicted uh one sample
at 31 picogram
had the prediction for brown color uh
and this was caused by the fact
that we had uh in one smith wrong allele
school that passed
the thresholds for coverage and
heterozygotic balance
the actual color of the hair was blonde
uh dark blonde
but we know that the individual was like
blonde as a child
uh so for the for the final interference
of uh ancestry
uh we first calculated that mixture and
they were predicted in
uh converge and so the software
uses a data set that includes
um genotype frequencies and population
data
for 145 smiths out of 165
and the method that converge is using
is called bootstrapping methods so a
random
set of sequence snips is analyzed
multiple times
and an average results of all of those
replications
is presented in the end um and
the admixture is presented as a
percentage of each population with a
corresponding likelihood and we have
seven populations included in converge
which is europe
southwest asia south asia east asia
africa
america um and oceania
and so here you can see that the
ancestry predictions the number of smith
fields was between 100 and 44 and 107
it's a
103.7 kilogram uh so the traditions were
correct for all of the inputs suggesting
european origin
we also use the same snip set and we run
the estimations in snipper they were
also all predicted as european
and in fact our example came from
germany
um to enhance the answer speed
predictions we also calculated
population likelihoods are using
frog and we decided for the lately
published standalone version
that allows to analyze multiple genomes
at once
um so um our snip set
it was tested on 96 populations and the
highest likelihood that we got
calculated was
irish mixed europeans and dense as men
as mentioned our sample was german but
germans are not included in a database
uh so for the last part the white
chromosome um
for the hyperbole prediction uh it was
the same down to 31 picogram and this
was the most derived snip within the
panel
and below that we only had the major r
haplogroup prediction
uh we also used nav gen and the ystr
data
to estimate the copper group as we
predict
and we confirmed the predicted lineage
uh so the second state of the validation
was testing the panel on non-reference
samples
and they were collected based on an
agreement with an ethic commission from
our university
uh and we asked volunteers uh to fill
out a questionnaire
when when they said declared the down to
the third generation
and described their phenotype and we
took pictures reference pictures for
comparison
so for this study we collected and used
124 samples from europe
84 of them were from germany we also had
11 non-european samples and five samples
that
were known to be admixed and so here the
outcome of the phenotype predictions for
all 140 samples
done using the guidelines for harris
plex s
for eye color three results were
inconclusive and the rest were predicted
as blue
or brown and 88 of those predictions
were correct uh for hair color and skin
color
we had predictions for all possible
colors and accordingly 78
and 89 of them were correct uh so those
values overall corresponds
with that was obtained during the
validation
of high-res plexus so here you can see a
graph that presents that mixture
predicted by converge for european
non-european
and the non-administ samples so if we
have a look at this in detail
here we can see the european samples
they were all assigned correctly to
europe
some of them showing admission mostly
with southwest asia
on the right you can see the results
from snipper all of the samples were
predicted as 100
european just as a comment the reference
said that we used in sniper didn't
include the samples from the middle east
uh we also calculated population
likelihoods that didn't bring
too much information as europeans are
pretty
complex population but with what we did
observe that for almost all of the
samples that
had that mixture european minister at
least 90
we had major european populations
available in the data set
with the highest likelihoods like irish
hungarians mixed europeans or dense and
the samples
and it had some southeast asian mixture
very often also has turkish population
or
ethnic groups like ashkenazi jews um
having the highest
values and when it comes to the why
happy groups
all of them uh were a typical european
haplogroups and also where the
particular lineages here
and now the non-european samples so we
had all together seven asian samples
uh we had the east asia that both by
sniper
and converge were predicted um correctly
also the population like inputs here
where all is asian
and for three of the samples the highest
one
uh even corresponded with the actual
ancestry of the individual
um then when you look at the southwest
asia samples
um they were at mixed uh showing a high
percentage of
europe uh and southeast asia uh and by
sniffer they were predicted
as only european or only south asian um
and the populations that were calculated
here at the highest
likelihood where all middle east and
even if the actual
uh population was in the database it
never got
um calculated with the highest uh like
he could
then for the africa we had an example of
east central and north african sample
so only one sample was assigned to
africa the one from central
i bought by uh converge and snipper when
we
when we look at the east african sample
it was mixed
with southwest asia and the sample from
north africa which actually came from
egypt was assigned as southwest asia
only
um and when it comes to the population
like you could
they corresponded with the
intra-confidential origin of the
individuals
and the last sample was from america it
had a declared jewish ancestry
and it was predicted as 100 european
uh so now we are moving to uh the next
samples
uh so here are the results uh from the
national tradition from converge and
above
uh is the expected admixture based on
the questionnaires put down
the third generations of the
grandparents uh
so we had example uh for example so this
was always an admixture of a european
individual and non-european individual
we had a situation where we had
admissions to north african
uh individuals uh and the difference
between those admixtures
and the admixtures that we got before
for the declared europeans was that we
observed
a higher nature of africa that we didn't
see before next to the southwest
asia and in one case um we had
um a male for which we also predicted
the wild hopper group
which was j1a which is rather infrequent
in europe
and this corresponded with the north
african ancestry of the individual
we also had an um interesting example
where we expected a mixture of south
america and
europe and what we got predicted was
europe and africa
so uh it is known that there are many
african lineages in south america
uh in this case the south american
lineage was female
so we will be looking closer at the
sample also the mitochondrial dna to
understand it better and
now we are moving to the last part and
the most interesting one which was
um studying facebook samples uh so this
was a blind study
uh where the the case for examples were
unknown because the first
person who was interpreting the result
didn't know their origin
we had 16 samples that were collecting
during the autopsies performed in our
institute
and 14 blood samples and two bone
samples
and then we were also able to test our
panel on
actual traces collected at the scene and
submitted by the bavarian police for
phenotyping
so we had different inputs for the
samples and different
degradation index we studied all of them
in duplicates
so this table here it's a sum up a
complex sum up of
all of the predictions that we were able
to perform and
all of the results that we got in the
gray box
you can see the bone samples they were
the most degradated ones
and you see that for one of them we
didn't have the phenotype prediction and
also we are lacking the
white half a group estimation for all of
the rest of the samples we
calculated that mixtures we calculated
the population like you could
and selected the y uh chromosome hampton
group
and additionally was this on the slides
but unfortunately i don't have time to
go into details
um it's the mitochondrial copper group
um that we also um predicted based on
the control region that we are
allowed legally to sequence for those
kind of uh cases
and this slide is a sum up of all of
those results coming together so the
predictions that we did
according to the final final type um and
the ancestry
so first the concordance with the with
the reference data when it comes to the
uh to the phenotype um in the green box
you can see all of the phenotypes that
were actually correct
um because we had the reference data
coming from the out of scene
for the rest of the samples the data was
lacking because
um the bodies were to decay or
skeletonized
and and when it comes to the ancestry
the information provided by the police
was a place of bread of those
individuals
and based on this all of the predictions
were correct except of one
um for the individual that we um
predicted to be european both based on
autosomal markers and haploid markers
as a place of grid and had stated brazil
and now the really last part of the
study
which was uh testing those actual traces
uh so um then the end of last year
we got our first case for phenotyping
from the bavarian police
um but back then our panel was still
being validated so the samples were
being
were also sent to innsbruck uh which was
running visage panel on it
uh so we had two traces from the scene
these are the results from the first
trait
the phrase and these are the results
from the second race um
based on the sdr we expected to have the
same contributor to both of them
and we got exactly the same predictions
for both traces
and what is the most important for us
also those results for the ancestry
and for the phenotype work according to
that with the results from disaster
uh so um can we solve the unsolvable i
think that this is a very complex
question that
still needs sometimes to be answered but
each study uh
in the skills of phenotyping brings us
closer and what we learned from our
research is that when we combine all of
those predictions together
they can really shed light on unknown
individuals
very important and informative are the
haploid markers
also the ones that we added into our
panels with the wiseness
uh we definitely think that we need more
samples to study
in the future to understand admissions
even better
uh and we already planned to use the
gathered and sequenced genotypes
to provide the missing frequency data
for german population
thank you very much uh in the end i
would like to acknowledge everyone
to help with this research because of
course
uh lots of people help with it and
thanks
to gmi especially about the past one who
discussed with us the concurrency
uh on the results that we got thanks for
demo fisher who are really really
helpful with designing and
going through all of the details with
the custom panel
and definitely my team without more i
would not get
those results today so thank you very
much
okay thank you uh for this uh very
interesting
presentation um
very nice data we don't have questions
yet
answered by the community uh but i was
wondering so you have a new law because
it always begins with uh having a law
that allows you to do this kind of
work so how does the law in germany uh
looks like so it's it's it's for
phenotyping but is it more specific on
that
so as i already mentioned and this is
important to understand
uh germany has federal states and they
can implement separate laws this is why
i gave an example of bavaria
which is a different as i mentioned so i
will just repeat it again
um on the nationwide level right now
uh since few months you can test the
sample for the phenotype
so you can go for hairs skin and
eye hair and skin color predictions
plus the biological age but not only
bavaria only
also different states already introduced
also the ancestry
so depending on which police department
would send us a sample it might be only
for the phenotype or it might be
phenotype plus the ancestry so far we
worked with the bavarian police so we
had
the uh uncharged funnel
okay another question
[Music]
when you're looking at trade samples
there's always the risk that you might
have a mixed sample so the perpetrator
and maybe
as the victim itself did you look at
these mixture samples as well and and
are you able to
to exclude these or how does it work in
your workflow
this is a good question because so far
uh for this validation we work only with
the single source samples
we also looked a bit at the mixtures but
you are not exactly sure if we are happy
with the results so we came up with a
different idea that i don't want to
spoiler here
but very likely we will be willing to
look also
at the mixtures but being sure that we
are looking at the single contributor
okay okay and
and did you already think about the way
you are going to report these results
uh to the investigators
uh this is of course another question
because uh
we of course know uh everyone who works
with the police
uh even though we very much respect
their work we also know that they can
sometimes only because of not
understanding the results maybe
over interpret them a bit so we would
like
to report it in the way to really
give them the proper information but
also do not suggest them anything
so um right now we are just discussing
uh also thanks to the experience that we
got when doing the recording study how
we could present those results
um so i think that from our own
understanding sometimes
uh we would go a bit further with those
predictions but we would prefer to stay
on a really safe level with the police
um so you know this is only elite we
we all know it that this is just
additional thing that can be added to
the investigation
sometimes maybe we'll really change the
investigation and help it uh so we are
currently
discussing what would be the smartest
way to really
help the police and make them follow the
investigation but also you know don't
leave them in the wrong direction yeah
this is of course very important okay
thank you so much for your presentation
um then we are moving forward to
another way of doing the typing that
many of us know and it's
a more conventional way of doing the
typing
um and the exciting news
i think is that we now have another
family member
of the sequencers that
can be used for conventional typing
during the fragment analysis so i would
like to introduce
carl abini who works at the department
of experimental diagnostic and
specialty medicine of the university of
bologna
in the beautiful city of bologna um
and carla has a very broad interest in
molecular genetics
as in general but also forensic sciences
kinship analysis
human identification x and y population
studies
doing work on mitochondrial dna and also
has an interest in forensic
pharmacogenetics
currently she works as an adjunct
professor
and a dna forensic analyst
and the title of her talk is when new
technology
meets small realities implementation of
the applied biosystem sex studio
i a hid genetic analyzer in a forensic
laboratory carla the floor is yours
hi hello good afternoon to everybody
thanks sander for your kind introduction
and thanks to them official scientific
for
inviting me to share with all of you
our recent experience on
with the the new seek studio hid
genetic analyzer in the forensic
genetics
laboratory of the university of bologna
sorry so
sorry i've some problem with slides
i don't know why
okay let me give you some
background about bologna and
show you where we are bologna is located
in the north of italy
in the emilia romania region and
the province accounts more than 1
million
of presidents according to the ministry
of interior statistics
in 2019 bologna
was the fourth city in italy for crime
records
the majority of crimes are related
to property crimes
like robberies and burglaries and
amongst
violent crimes rapes
are the most common even if
characterized by a lower frequency rate
also domestic violence is important to
be mentioned
as often it is a hidden phenomenon
bologna is pleased to host the oldest
university of the western world from
1088 and the forensic genetics
laboratory is part
of the legal medic medicine unit
together with the forensic toxicology
laboratory
and the medical examiner and forensic
pathologist
pathologist teams as well as the
bioethics section
dealing with the progress in scientific
research and the technological
application of life
being part of the university the main
goals of the forensic genetics
lab are research projects
and student training in different degree
programs
currently the principal research area
covers the body fluid identification
by rna profiling approach and mutilation
detection
the influence of surfaces and
contaminants
on the dna typing detached dna
and its transfer the analysis of the
genetic polymorphism in drug response
and toxicity and str's allele
frequencies determination
in human population studies
moreover the lab has constant
collaboration
with experts all over the world in
different
biomedical sciences
the dna forensic lab activity started
in the early 90s and today our
team involves a small number of
forensic expert and fully training
dna analysts the same situation
affects many italian small university
laboratories
the type of evidence samples analyzed
range from all biological fluids to
human remains
as well as tissues sorry
the dna technology has been applied not
only to resolve cases of paternity and
kinship controversies
but also for individual identification
in several criminal criminal cases and
for species
identification the request
to perform dna analysis come
from both judicial authority and all
private customers
and cover all kind of forensic genetics
application
as a small lab we do not have a huge
number of
case work but we do collaborate with the
judicial authority thank you to the
trust
relationship built during in the past
years
and for our fast and rapid work around
time
constant partnership with the law
enforcement
police forces and prosecutors
offices characterized our activity
moreover the forensic genetics
laboratory of bologna is part of the
jeffrey group
the italian-speaking working group of
international society of forensic
genetics
so far the traditional workflow for dna
profiling
consists in a preliminary examination of
the evidence
followed by manual dna extraction the
quantitation
the quantification is performed using
the quantifier tier
kit on a 7500
real-time pcr system and we used
to have a 9700 pcr
thermal cycler in the very old 310
each steps represented here
is performed in separated in the
dedicated rooms
we have an average of more than 3000
samples
per year run on the platform even if the
lab
equipment has always been under
continuous
maintenance an update was mandatory in
view of the laboratory accreditation
and due to the discontinuation of the
old platforms
for us this was a challenge because the
main source of funding
is the forensic service for public and
private customers
for this reason we were aware
that we could not trust on institutional
or government
funds in fact it is well known about
the worldwide crisis of forensic
sciences
for lack of resources and adults
of fry of the financial funding
in this situation the task from
companies
and foundation which promotes calls for
research project
focused on social utility and local
security
is essential for the more reality as
ours
on this way the first step
was to replace the discontinued
thermal cycle with the new applied
biosystem verity
next thanks thanks to the bank
foundation
pasadena spammy of bologna we could
apply
for funds presenting a project on
the improvement of dna testing policy
standards
for forensic application with the aim
to help justice and criminal
investigation
and we are we were able to replace our
310
after 22 years of great job
we were among the first in italy to have
the first capillary electrophoresis
platform
back in 1997 and now we are pleased to
be the first
italian laboratory to get the new
studio genetic analyzer for human
identification
compared to the old instrument the sixth
studio hid
fits perfectly with our needs and has
many facilities
and advantages as you can imagine the
change has been amazing for us
especially for that concerning the
maintenance
and resolution
here i show you some new appealing
features
of the six studios
the first is the cartridge that
has four capillaries for a total of
one thousand injection in the life span
of six
months this aloha allows us
the flexibility that we need without
wasting regent especially because
the lab has a variable sample process
rate
when there's la with with the slide in
and
all in cartridge containing
array capillaries polymer and buffer
there is a reduced setup and maintenance
times allowing a more efficient
turnaround time
to give you a practical example during
the lockdown
the instrument was stopped for two
months
and when the laboratory activity got
back
just a pds refresh was sufficient
to put the instrument back up and
running
this is very very easy to perform
the only manual care is the replacement
of the
cathode buffer vial every 15 days
and checking that the buffer volume has
not dropped below the limit
moreover you have the possibility to
combine
fragment and sequence analysis in the
same round
but at the moment not sequence and the
hid fragment analysis not yet
the eigen throughput and the easy and
fast instrument setup
contribute to increase the productivity
of the lab
last but not the least the competitive
price
was in line with our budget resources
limited to a small laboratory
one more feature is the possibility to
monitor data in real time from any
mobile devices
by time official official cloud
cloud tool but unfortunately right now
is forbidden for
us due to the university privacy rules
we had installation and training of six
student hid
at the end of november 2019
and in december we started with the
activity on the instrument
but unfortunately we we ran a limited
number of samples during the past months
and we had to stop our internal
validation
due the pandemic lockdown therefore we
don't have a great experience of
all tools the system provides
so far we have been conducting
concordance studies
for both hiv str and sequence analysis
and we also run the gaetna proficiency
test
in duplicate using both identify laplace
and global filing kits moreover since
the six studio enables us to have the
six die capability
we are introducing in our routine work
the new global phyla accucr kit
optimized for case or samples
and we hope to complete its internal
validation
as soon as possible
now i want to show you some examples
the of the analysis on
studio hid the main improved effect
between the two capillary
electrophoresis
instrument is a definitely increased
resolution
especially more evident for sequence
analysis
as you can see in this example from a
mitochondrial dna
sequence of the same sample this
improvement is due to the polymer pop
one
which has greater resolving power
compared
to to pop four
this agar resolution ability potentially
could result peaks
intrinsic to the amplification but
as you can see in this example of
complex mixed profile
run on six studio hid the algorithm
introduced in the data collection
software version
1.2 helps keeping the resolution similar
to the traditional one
avoiding the call of peaks in the minus
one and plus one position
in this slide i show you an example of
concordance study using
identify laplace kit on both 310
and six today platforms
as you can see the dna size sites in
data quality
are comparable between the two
instruments
but the quality system included in gym
map
version 1.6 is the very new useful
feature for us
used to to the mapper version 3.2
and the colorway the colorway colorway
the editors
indicating if the site meet
the analysis requirements and pass it to
the to streamline the result
interpretation
so i have no more time for
show you to show you more example but
i'd like to show
what's going on what's going on the
first step
of course is the conclusion of the
internal validation
with different kits including wi-fi plus
with 27 lucy and then we
would to set up snips analysis on the
music studio
for forensic pharmacogenetics and y
and mitochondrial dna genetic markers
application then we also decided to
upgrade
the instrument for real-time pcr
replacing the one currently present with
the newport studio system
more investing in the it infrastructure
is one of the most challenging
challenging
tasks facing the probabilistic
genotyping software
one of the main goal is to increase the
dna
team raising awareness of the
institution
on the forensic science impact on the
society
and finally to move trusting
to move towards the automation of the
nuclei acid extraction will make
the lab workflow more efficient
i would like to thank my lab the
director
the carisball foundation all the
forensic group of
the legal medicine unit the staff
of them official scientific especially
laura ricardi for technical support
and of course all of you for your
attention
thank you
okay thank you carla for this very nice
presentation
and it's good to see that we we also
have these kind of equipment
to uh to be able to service the smaller
lab as
as the one yours is um
and comparing it to the 310 it brings
back memories not only for me but also
one of the people in the audience has 22
years of experience with the 310
that's amazing
it is because it's still in the lab
and it's working uh it's working
very better it's not possible to go
with this instrument
so you're using both sequencing methods
and
fragment analysis on the on the new
system is it
easy to swap between the two
applications
yes you can do in the same same
run model there is the possibility to
run both fragment analysis and sequences
but not for at the moment
for hid fragment analysis
this is
[Music]
this is because the uh
the
the the the support of thermo fisher
scientific
knows where very well their
chemical the chemistry of their kids
and so they they cannot
[Music]
you can you can you can do you you
you will can do uh
in the future uh for all all
for fragment analysis and sequencing
uh from uh from different kids
i i don't know if i ever answered the
your your question sorry
it's okay it's okay thank you um
because of time i think yeah
because of time i think we should move
forward thank you so much again
carla for your presentation thank you
and then we go from the conventional way
of doing the
str typing to the rapid ways of doing
the typing
[Applause]
so the next presentation will be on the
replicate id
by dr stefan konema stefan
worked uh for um i counted eight years
at the institute of legal medicine
in munster so a different uh different
city in germany a scientific researcher
and also as a lab manager
uh but now he's a senior field
application specialist
on the extraction method but also on the
rapid rapid dna
um and actually i had the pleasure to
meet uh to meet steph on
real life before the crisis hid in
because he visited identify a few times
to talk about rapid
rapid dna rapid instruments
and he's really the true expert on on
rapid
rapid id so i'm very pleased to
to be able to announce him his the title
of this presentation will be application
of the applied biases and graphite id
system current results
and application examples
so stefan the floor is yours
thank you very much for this nice
introduction
so yeah i would like to present you now
the repetiti id and some nice examples
i don't want to talk about so
much the how the systems work
there are other possibilities here at
this conference
you can go to the booth and things alike
and check and also have an expert chat
later but let me tell you that
the repetit and the rapid dna
is not a replacement for the current
workflow we see it as an addition
so here's a comparison of cost and
throughput
and although the rapid analysis
is more expensive than
the normal lab workflow the ce workflow
there's definitely applications and
one is the flexibility and the mobility
but yeah if you are interested
in this um there's
possibilities here and there's also a
poster presentation
about rapid that you can have a look at
yeah
what we did as an as i now give you some
examples
where i have used rapid in our darmstadt
hid experience lab in germany
is that we analyzed bones
together with the institute of legal
medicine
in minds together with dr uttamur and dr
klaus bender
and for that we choose some bones
that were collected by the institute of
legal medicine and mines
and we used a steel drill six millimeter
steel drill and
drilled into the bone to
have some material for the rapid dna
analysis
i can show you here there is
an example of such a drill
it had a weight of about 56
milligram of weight and
this weight is similar to what we
recommend
when we do an extraction
a common extraction with the automate
express or the prepfiler express
bta chemistry from applied biosystems
thermofisher
you can see another example
of drills of about 84 milligram of
weight
and you can see them on the right
already in the analysis
chamber where you put the sample of
unrepetitive id
into cartridge as you might be aware
there's two different kinds of
cartridges mainly on the repetitive id
it's the ace and the intel cartridges
and the
intel cartridges are more sensitive
than the ace cartridges so you can use
them
for stain samples cramping samples as
well
where we the ace sample cartridges
are more for reference samples you can
also analyze
blood or saliva with them
[Music]
so here's an example now an analysis
result with the bone
chips that we have put into the
repetitive
intel cartridge and there is a
good profile of course with
the intel cartridges is good
when an expert also has a look
at the results but yeah
is quite nice good
results what we also did
was that we heard
that there's like a trial um a
disaster victim identification trial
and for that of course not real bones
were used from the actors
but um the toenails were used
in this dvi trial so we also
tested toenails we just cut them
and put them into the repetitive id
intel cartridge
here's an example of
about 20 milligram of
toenails so there are
you can see different pieces
of toenails is from one person
it can be very different you can take
one
toenail from a participant it might be
very big
but some have of course tinier toenails
and you need to collect a little bit
more but
nevertheless 20 milligram is not too
much
and also these gave a good
profile for
comparison and
yeah for later using
these results for identification
possibly
what i think is very interesting
is that you can reuse
the samples that you have put into the
repetitive id
intel cartridges and what i did
was that i used the get knob samples for
this
some of you might be aware about get
knob but
for those who are not aware about get
knob
i can say that git knob sends out three
reference samples
and four stain samples um two times
each year where the participants have to
find the correct allele calls
for these reference and stained samples
and
if they do this correctly um
yeah they will get a certificate and
more than
200 labs all over europe participated
so the slides that you can see here were
given me by dr carsten horov
he's also participating in this
conference and
they are two years old now these numbers
i think they are now with getting up at
more or less 250 participants
but yeah there's countries where there
are a lot of labs participating
some others a little less but get knob
is very important if you want to see
if your dna analysis you do are correct
or not so what i did
i took the getup samples and i cut them
into half with a scissor
and i used one half for the repetit
200. it's the big white instrument
that you've seen at the beginning it's
for up to eight samples
and the other half i've put into the
repetitive id
it's the small black instrument that
you've seen is for one sample
and both run with the global filer
express chemistry
after that after the analysis on the id
was finished i took the whole cartridge
and i've frozen it for a later analysis
with the normal lab extraction
workflow and extraction and
ce workflow and um
yeah um when i took them out after they
were frozen
i have quantified them with our
quantifier i've extracted them with prep
file express quantified them
with quantifier trio and then amplified
them with the global filer
and they used 0.5 nanograms
of dna and here
you can see now firstly
the results that i got on the repetitive
id
with half of the gitmap stain
good profile and here's
a result from the repetitive 200
also quite nice profile
and yeah these were reference samples
but more
interesting are i think the mixed stain
samples
so i also have results here so this is
stain one of the getting up samples on
the repetitive
200 and
here you can see stain run stain one
on the repetitive id
and yeah just to make you aware
the repetitive id intel cartridges
have a higher cycle number
so when you looked at
the stain profile and there was
obviously a two-person mixture
but there were also alleles of only one
base pair of difference in d1s
1656 and
also some elevated stutter and if you
now want to
secure the results that you have um
as i said i've run these samples i've
re-extracted
them and then run them on the seek
studio
and here's what you see with
the repetitive id results might be
elevated stutter
also on the left yeah there's
two peaks with only one base pair of
difference
and when you now run them
on the seek studio that's what you get
the seek studio results
amplified with the global phyla
chemistry
and there's some quite nice
results as well and so you can confirm
the results that you had on the id
and together with the results that you
have
on the seek studio
okay so yes as i said the repetitive
systems are a perfect addition to your
current lab workflows
it's not a replacement this is a perfect
addition
um yeah and these samples that you have
run on the repetitive id
system with intel cartridges for example
you can re-analyze them with common
laboratory
workflow methods
so this together with the get knob
samples for example is a good way
to test and verify your repetitive
systems and yeah
we've already analyzed as well samples
that can be taken in disaster victim
identification
and it worked and if you have any
questions
we'll be happy to implement your repetit
system and your repetitive workflow
please go to the poster section
and there you will see some results
that we have generated on the bones
samples together with
the minds um inter
legal medicine institute and
we have also compared then the results
that we have
on the id um against the results
that we got on ce i have not shown it
here but
it's in the poster session and now there
will be
an expert chat open where chris bridge
and me
and chris bridges my colleague also very
much
involved in rapid will answer your
questions
so that's from me okay thank you stefan
thanks for your very clear presentation
on the record id
um i see there's one question
uh coming up uh asking what's the total
time needed for the extraction and
typing
together uh on
on the id other i think on the
repetitive id
the analysis time of the sample is about
90 minutes and then when
the sample is
uploaded to the rapid link software
i could not talk about it now but i'm
happy to answer this question the
expert chat later what rapid link is um
yeah you you can have immediately
the result right so um
if you are um behind it
um does not take much longer than 90
minutes then you also have the analysis
profile
and on the repetitive 200 it takes about
two hours
until you get the samples analyzed
and then of course when they are
uploaded to rocket link
you can have immediately the
electrophorogram the profile yeah
okay another question is would a
reanalysis from a rapid hit cartridge
extracted material in a classical
workflow work if the input material
concentration is
too low for the rapid hit
for the rapid yeah i think yeah as i
understand
so you you have no result on the
repetitive id for example
because the sample input was too low
there were not enough cells and
then it works in if i re-extract it
um with a normal lab workflow i didn't
have this case and i have not tested it
but i could imagine
yes that although there was possibly
no result on the repetitive id and that
when you re-extract the sample that
there could still be
a profile not maybe not the best one
but at least maybe a partial profile i
could imagine that but i have never
tested it okay so that's something that
you should really test if you
are yes right using this system
um another question is in the future are
you looking to install a quantification
step into the machines to measure the
dna concentration
i'm not aware
of this but it's it's not
um yeah it's not how this
uh system yeah was
is intended for so when you have
extracted the dna and then
do a quantification step
and then maybe guess the best input
amount of dna
yeah then yeah
would be another application is global
file express chemistry
that we use for these cartridges and
um yeah so at this point we don't
quantify
and i i'm not aware um
i'm not speaking for for thermo fisher
as a whole now at least i can say i'm
not aware that we want to
add the quantification step okay
well it's a question that comes up uh um
more often
when talking about rapid because uh and
and there are there are
quite some countries around the world
where it's obligatory to have a
quantification
in your complete process for dna
profiling in forensics
um if we're talking about uh stain
samples
okay um given the time i think
we should wrap it up so i would like to
again thank
all the speakers of today for their very
good presentations
and thank them fisher for organizing
this online event
a job well done something to
also think about for the future probably
thank you all for your attention and i
will give back the floor
to louise who will finish up this this
session
all right thank you again sander also
for sharing this session
thank you to all of our speakers and
thank you to the audience
for your outstanding questions as a
final reminder
any questions that were submitted and
not answered today by our speakers will
be addressed separately and posted on
the on-demand view of hits virtual
these presentations will be available
for on-demand viewing
until june 2021 please be sure to share
them with
any of your colleagues who might be
interested in any of the topics covered
in today's session
thank you again for your participation
we are now opening the technical ask the
expert chat that stephen also just
mentioned
don't miss it also the applications hall
exhibits and posters are open
please be sure to stop by see you at
hits 2021
take care and goodbye